ladies and gentlemen your breaking news
this happened just a few minutes ago it
appears that Matt Walsh has been hacked
on Twitter and uh we're sitting here
we're trying to figure out what the the
big story of the day is you've got
Anheuser-Busch is getting tremendous
support from the American public you've
got this story about this teenager who
was shot and then sure enough I think uh
four minutes to go or whatever Phil
Labonte he's like uh Matt Walsh just
tweeted that my pronouns are that and uh
words there's an N word and then uh he
says Joe wrote he calls Joe roganapito
he says he can confirm that Andrew Tate
kidnapped and raped some girls it looks
like someone might have actually stolen
his phone because they just put up a
picture that has uh someone took a
picture of what looks like it might be
his phone where people are texting him
it looks like there's a Google
authentication code in there Microsoft
account security code Twitter
authentication code so yeah I don't want
to show that yeah we got some silly
tweets where he's like he said Ben
shapir you know what you did and calls
him he calls him gay you know but I
don't want to pull up any of Matt
Walsh's private information but uh
ladies and gentlemen I am I am a
privileged individual in that I have the
phone numbers of people at the daily
wire and since it happened I'm sorry I
ruined the fun of whoever these people
are and I immediately called him I was
like guys uh get on this I'm assuming
they were you know it's the hardest
thing
because you never want to just be that
random nosy like I don't work as a daily
wire or anything like that for all I
know I call them and they're like yes we
know we're on it like okay bye like I
sorry to waste your time guys but I I
think they it like we caught it right
when it happened and uh you know oh geez
wait okay what's a Matt Walsh blog let
me I'm pulling up Matt Walsh's Twitter
account on a separate screen because I
want to show any of his private
information
yeah he's got a tweet there my Twitter
isn't hacked this is just the real me
coming out and it's a picture of that
phone you said you should not lend your
phone to anybody in case anybody out
there doesn't it's crazy to think how
much is centralized in these phones now
yeah I mean yeah but this is this is
there's no way this is a prank this this
has to be so I'm looking at it right now
I'm not going to show it on the show I
can't because it says uh someone someone
texted Matt and it says your Twitter has
been hacked right and but the number
isn't saved which means they likely
cloned his SIM card I was just gonna say
it's like yeah it might be not the
actual uh actual let me let me see if I
if I know uh whose number this is on top
of that if you look underneath there you
see like the Google verification code
Twitter authentication code so they
probably went through and reset it to
that phone in order to like you know
remake right so you can use you can do
that with the original phone and then
move it to another phone which is
probably what they did and it's happened
to me before when people have said hey I
am out of battery do you mind if I just
use your phone to make a phone call and
increase recently I've just had to say
it's also on the East Coast Matt Walsh
is I don't I mean Matt Walsh is either
in LA or he's in Nashville I thought
good call yeah it's our time zone yeah
this is our time zone so so okay so so
I'll stress this
what likely happened is uh
oh man I almost I want to describe how
to do it because I don't want to spread
that information I don't know but simply
put it is very easy to clone someone's
SIM card
and once you do you can put into any
phone and then when you log into their
account you'll get all of their
passwords you'll get all of their you'll
you get you get everything you get two
two factor and all that stuff so I don't
know uh what what else
uh Phil you said there's some something
else but but this is image the image in
the image the time is uh East Coast time
because it was posted the picture was
posted six minutes ago in the uh in the
image it says 8 PM 801 is is when the
the image was taken of the phone here
yeah yeah the reason the reason there's
there's that reason the reason why I
think this is legit a hack is that um
one the phone number that messaged this
phone and said your Twitter has been
hacked
there's no name if it was actually Matt
Walsh the name would be saved which
implies a Sim clone but then also it
shows security codes for a bunch of
different accounts and Google account
yeah right that's like leaking very
serious access and information and the
Twitter account which tells you they've
probably changed the password right at
that time 7 22 PM right Eastern so they
changed the password Twitter sent the
auto authentication code and now they're
into this Google they're into Microsoft
and you know once you're into that stuff
yeah it's kind of game over yeah wow
uh it's also
man uh
what dude where's Elon Musk
on the horn baby well I mean if it if
they did get a you know if they actually
have the hardware or like it's probably
like you said a clone because because of
the times that's what I believe because
of the time zone stuff there's not much
that anyone in particular can do he's
gonna have to make do the running around
of closing all of his accounts and
handling all that stuff individually on
a laptop or whatever is going to cut the
call all of his banking stuff it's going
to be a huge headache good luck that's
so weird why would they post this photo
if they actually hacked it that's like
when you said they posted the picture of
a phone I'm like why would someone give
up like they're they're incriminating
themselves or making it much easier to
find out who did this
well Kellen just mentioned me that
there's uh bio and true references some
rapper named like I don't want to say
the name of it um but according to him
it says that the bio and tweet
references some some rapper I don't want
to say the name and then it links to the
the
um Spotify for that rapper right really
right it says on the thing you can see
sassy Shooters a little hack job I I
just I'm clicking no links
I imagine that it wouldn't actually be
the person that did the because this is
politically motivated it's Matt Walsh
obviously and so they just probably you
know got some random dudes rap or you
know that's that that's got a mixtape or
whatever or something like that
um
but I don't imagine that the actual
rapper got a hold of his thing and is
like yo I'm gonna get Matt Walsh's
information so that way I can actually
promo my mixtape I just feel like it's
more about you know getting at Matt
Walsh because he's Matt Walsh but the
promos very telling that's and they they
splattered their promo multiple times on
the Twitter page already I mean yeah I
don't know about that like frame
somebody you know what I mean that's a
good point I mean maybe you know why how
do you protect your sim card oh sorry to
interrupt is this is this indicative
that his phone was out of his hands when
it was taken no no no it was crazy I
don't want to describe how easy it is to
do man I like I
I will say this
you don't need the device
you don't need any physical object
you only need a phone number that is so
crazy man that's it this world where we
think we have any kind of security it's
all oh no yeah it's all an illusion
there is no security anymore the idea of
security security is
always what can you air gap
if you don't have an air gap then you do
not that means that means it has to be
only Hardware has to have no Wi-fi
ability plug-in only and you own you
never plug it into like some kind of
internet that you don't know I mean
super hard to be here's the other thing
to consider
all of Matt Walsh's direct messages have
just been exfiltrated
that like
yeah
so all that stuff I said to Matt if you
guys had a braiding it it's totally a
joke
no I I was like I I was I was thinking
that I've only the only thing I've ever
said was uh like good movie guy or
something like that Matt Walsh is uh his
uh his direct messages and stuff they're
probably one step more edgy than Mitt
Romney
about that I because I just I he's like
you know I mean he probably gets fired
up and says some bad things about trans
people but other than that which the
trans people are are already completely
convinced that he's gonna say that you
know the most terrible things that you
could possibly say about them from you
know Matt Walsh so I'm like do I need to
try and should I do something I don't
know you know part of me is kind of like
is mind my own business stay out of it I
I felt bad enough actually calling the
daily wire guys and being like hey do
you guys know this because I feel like
it's intrusive or whatever I mean it was
right but like I could also reach out to
people at Twitter and be like hey you
know but I'm like is it my place I I
don't imagine that there's a whole like
I said I don't imagine that there's a
whole lot that can be done like the real
damage is the stuff that they've got
behind the scenes never mind his Twitter
account sure it exposes stuff but yeah
right to consider this
whoever did this they probably did a lot
more before revealing that they did it
if they're smart yeah yeah
I can't believe they posted this image
of the phone though I mean does that
just give so much away 7 22 PM is when
they when they when they broke in hacked
is already trending of 40 000 tweets
about it wow man yo this is crazy what's
going on
but this is uh uh so you know this just
happened and I think this is an element
of
look we saw Riley Gaines try to give a
speech and they threatened her life they
chase her into a room she gets locked in
what was it like three hours she's
locked in as people are screaming and
demanding money yeah this is another
component look people get hacked all the
time I don't want to act like you know
what's happening to Matt Walsh's like
the first time anyone's ever been hacked
or whatever but you got to recognize I
mean for us here we've been swatted we
were spotted 15 times in a year yeah
this is the stuff that comes with the
territory thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time